I trained in the mornings from about
10:00 till 3:00 that is a combination of
jumping on trampolines and then the
strength and conditioning
I'd say my max height is about 30 feet
it truly feels like you're flying it's
the closest thing there's a cross in the
middle of the trampoline that we always
keep our eyes on and if you lose that
you're in trouble I guess you guys had
to figure out like which angles work the
best on certain takeoffs to get you the
highest and which ones make you rotate
the fastest like on vault you have to
hit the table a certain way in a certain
angle so you kind of need to go over and
over and over again to get it perfect
you think about the beam it's four
inches wide it's like thinner than the
sidewalk curb you know if your timings a
little bit off you can wipeout or miss
your hand when you're going for a double
back so it is like muscle memory to
trust yourself and to think about the
little corrections in a trick we
initiate the flip with the power through
our legs we don't want any of the
momentum to escape through our body so
we're as straight as possible and then
twisting we initiate with our shoulders
if I start to travel amongst the
trampoline I might bend my knees a
little bit more on the take-off and send
myself back or I'll push my hips forward
when you're doing a roundoff back
handspring into a double back what I
think about is just keeping my elbows in
my legs really straight because if you
bend your elbows then you'll kind of
just collapse in your back handspring
and if you're really tight then you'll
be able to get more power it's very very
small adjustments though because the
force of the trampoline is so great you
might end up on the ground but for the
most part we are pretty skilled at
knowing where we are at all times
you